le musée d'art contemporain le musée des
beaux-arts de montréal s'unissent pour
un projet commun qui va donc provoquer
la rencontre de leurs oeuvres
respectives tenir la boîte
deux musées rassembler sous un même toit
jusqu'à l'été prochain le musée des
beaux-arts accueillera en ses murs des
oeuvres du musée d'art contemporain qui
célèbre ses 50 ans et c'est la toute
première fois que ces deux grandes
institutions montréalaises s'unissent
d'une façon formelle pour une exposition
dans chaque salle on retrouve des
oeuvres d'art contemporain issus des
deux musées de valérie blass a highway
comme l'indiquent le titre de
l'exposition un plus un égale 1 les deux
collections ne sont pas mises en
opposition mais présentés en
complémentarité tout est en rapport on
est vraiment à la perspective
d'expansion de montréal métropole
culturelle c'est nathalie bondil qui a
initié ce projet commun qui permet au
musée des beaux-arts de montréal de
présenter de nouvelles acquisitions
alors que pour le musée d'art
contemporain c'est l'occasion de faire
rayonner sa collection qui par manque d
espace reste en grande partie cachée
dans ses voûtes on est ravi de pouvoir
partager ses magnifiques chefs-d'oeuvre
de la collection qui seraient
normalement simplement
dans la noirceur dans un entrepôt
quelque part
cette exposition ouvre la porte à de
futures collaborations artistiques
il aura probablement d'autres d'autres
événements pourquoi pas si par exemple
le musée d'art contemporain donc doit
fermer ses portes pour s'agrandir s'il
doit déménager peut-être que nous
pourrions avoir un mac hors les murs ici
tout est possible il n'ya pas il n'y a
pas de stratégie si ce n'est que de
jouer collectif un plus un égale ainsi
aussi deux musées ayant une vision
commune ici tanya lapointe à
radio-canada mourir